il y a une parole de Monsieur Darmanin
dans le monde de ce matin qui est quand
même étonnante
il dit qu'il demande au préfet
de veiller à rendre la vie des gens
impossibles les gens qui sont sous TF
mais ils ne sont pas des délinquants ils
sont sous occupés F mais c'est bizarre
quand même vous ne trouvez pas un
ministre de l'Intérieur qui demande au
préfet de rendre la vie des gens
impossibles moi si j'étais ministre de
l'Intérieur je ne suis pas je ne dois
pas être capable d'avoir une scie haute
une
ossiotte stature enfin je veux dire au
préfet de régler les problèmes un préfet
on lui demande de traiter les questions
de régler les problèmes est-ce que vous
trouvez normal que le ministre de
l'Intérieur demande au préfet de rendre
la vie des gens impossibles c'est
étrange
[Musique]